hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I am
your co-host Geo vonna
Antoinette Quan
and um
yeah
I like that all right so I'm gonna just
jump right into it what makes you want
to meet new people like what the is
that all about
you never watched the uh Matthew
McConaughey clip pretend I didn't
he says uh one of the things that was
his favorite about like I think dropping
his kid off at school or at like summer
camp or something
and he's like well he told me was
that he gets to do fun things and
um
meet new people and what more in life do
you want uh is this a
Christopher Walken
he's much sexier though I don't know no
but pretty much what he said was I was
very funny uh was
um in life all you have is being able to
do cool and then meet new people
and that's what life really is damn
that's so good yeah because I have zero
inkling zero inspiration
zero desire
to want to meet anyone you I feel like
what's your definition of a cool life
then
um
I already have my cool friends
and then just doing with the people
I already that are like in my circle so
having the cool friends that you never
hang out with I'm about to hang out with
them I'm leaving tomorrow as a matter of
fact like once every four months hey
that's all I need baby do you forget who
you're talking to
the lockdown was Disneyland for
me are you kidding me so your definition
of a cool life is stay at home not stay
at home
but it's to not be your home people
so hiking is awesome camping is awesome
by yourself with my circle of
people my friends that's it who's in
your circle
my friends like who uh you Joe David
Hanna now who's awesome and I
adore her my brother his family my
girlfriend Bonnie Steffy uh uh Alexandra
like I just have just different people
now and how often do you uh need to do
this how often do I need to maybe once a
quarter
wow your true true introvert
yeah I am that's when you're like I want
to get to know this person I want to get
to know that person I'm like
so for me what does anyone want to do
I'm pretty introverted I would say
compared to like my counterpart Joe
right oh you guys are
Polar Opposites yeah like to me he is
the quintessential extrovert where
conventions big things super down well
yeah he's so sad right talk to every
single person
um like even for me like I remember like
we're such on the same page we can go to
the best museum in the world literally
like the Louvre and we see one Hall
where like I think we're good you know
every time we like we went to the Getty
with it was you me Joe and uh we were
like oh shoot this is new like I think
it was a samurai exhibit or something
this would be so super cool like I've
never seen before a photograph of
Samurai right we go there we see like
the suit two black and white photos
we're like all right let's go get some
food or something and Joe was like going
every single photo can we stay longer
can we stay longer and I I swore if it
was up to him he would have been there
the whole day
and so when I compare myself to him
I'm like
I'm definitely an introvert but I think
the difference where I've probably sit
in the middle between and Joe and you I
think Joe is down with mass interaction
Mass contact and full immersion
for me
um
I like to hand pick who I meet
so with that Matthew McConaughey like uh
quote for me it's like I want to meet
cool people and emphasis on cool
so when I was able to spend some
one-on-one time with Tim Kennedy that is
rad like if I could spend
one-on-one time with Dave Chappelle or
even recently um I start I started
hanging out with a neighbor in our
community like he's so interesting to me
so when I am able to meet with like cool
interesting people one-on-one I love
that because I get to expand my brain
you know like um
probably due to Joe Rogan's podcast
I have become a lot of friends now no no
I've become smarter than I've ever been
yeah right because just the people that
he could bring in into the conversations
expert in uh uh epigenetics expert in
sleep ex Rick Rubin one of the best
music producers of all time like how
often can you
when will you ever meet them on that
intimate level yeah you'll never be able
to meet these caliber of people but
because of him they can talk and we get
to absorb through osmosis so for me uh
me being able to meet people like that
in person is even better it's better
than osmosis because now I'm asking the
questions that I want and I'm absorbing
what I want to absorb so I'm not into
Mass interaction I don't want to find
the diamond and the rough
um I want to just find the diamond and
spend time with the diamond yeah uh but
that I feel like that enriches me like
one aspect of me but then the other side
is similar to you I just want to do dope
stuff with my friends
um and so that's
really important to me too but there's
the other half where like I like
because I also realize some of my
friends don't care about the other
that I like yeah yeah so I think I get
that satisfaction in other areas yeah I
get that yeah yeah so for me I think
that's where the difference is where you
like the connection to be one-on-one
whereas for me I like it to be in a
group dynamic because when it's
one-on-one because I'm so introverted
and I have like a a bank right like I
forgot where we got this but there's
like
a bank of like you know a certain amount
of energy some people
uh get get more energy uh deposited into
this Bank when they meet and talk to
more people so the more interactions
they get this bank account gets bigger
and bigger right AKA Joe
um then there's people like me with
every single interaction I have with
people my energy just depletes depletes
depletes depletes pleats so because the
depletion happened so quickly for me I
need to have it in a group setting so
that's why I like being around my circle
of friends because everyone is so
interesting brings so many different in
perspectives and and like ideas and
hobbies and stuff into the group like
Joe's not the same as David the only
commonality here is that you guys are
comedians right
um other than that there's like a lot of
differences between a lot of our friends
but what I do like is when if and when I
need to meet someone new I like it in a
group setting because one it at least
for me it tells me a lot about them how
they interact with certain people
um so I get to see like I get to be like
outside looking in I get to hear how
they talk you know their ideas and I
don't have to interact with it so that's
what I like so then as soon as I'm like
like assessing their character in a
group setting I'm still conserving my
energy because would you prefer a
podcast over meeting them in real life
then
because then it's the same thing that
someone else is interacting and you get
to just be there and assess I
would say yes for the initial but then
if I find them to be very interesting
and I'm drawn to them then I would want
to meet them in real life but again in a
group setting I don't really like
one-on-ones there's there's a very few
people that I like spending one-on-one
time with do you have any Idols or
someone you're like super fascinated by
[Music]
you could buy a lot of people name one
of them
literally like I think everyone is
fascinating I really do think everyone
is fascinating name one
even the ladies cleaning our house right
now I think they're one okay
let's say
Kane is outside
fascinating you'd be like okay let me
hit up four people so that because I can
hang out with them versus like yo
hey Khan you want to come in and like I
don't think I can do that
so you think you could bond with him
better with three other people
um yeah because I don't have to do any
of the I'm not even trying to find the
bond yet because I need to figure out if
I even want to share my bond side of it
because for bonding takes two people
right yeah I'm trying to see if it's
even worth me opening up this energy
Bank to even make that connection to
even begin to bond because it's going to
wear your ass out possibly right so if
if if he's anything like what I think he
is right
um in terms of like so I know him for
like he got Bonkers right that
aside I'm very impressed with like his
artistic side of things right the
designer the musician the producer uh I
think he actually draws so I'm very
intrigued by that
okay so he's outside
I'm gonna be like
what if he's just he's just that he's
not he doesn't really know how to
communicate and we don't have any type
of connection I'm like I just
wasted this energy
and I don't think I care enough
to want to even put that out there
wow yeah it's bad you're a waste
of a human being why that's horrible
take that back take it back right
now take it back right now I'm not a
waste of a human being take it back
you're a waste of Kanye's time
possibly that's why I wouldn't even
waste his time I'm not even gonna
interact with him you don't have a uh
thirst of knowledge
I do but how I get it is different than
yours how do you get it
second hand
so that's that's the part that's so
funny you know because to me I'm like
David Chang comes
David please please get out of my
kitchen
write some notes no no that's not it I'm
gonna read it later no that's not what
would happen he comes into my kitchen
I'm quiet
I'm just in the room flat on the wall
now
if you talk to me cool I'll engage in
that but for me to go out of my way to
engage I just I don't have that but I
don't want to what knowledge is he
quenching of yours none so we probably
won't even talk so that's what I'm
saying so you don't have a thirst for
knowledge I do
but are you quite sure thirst of
knowledge I'll probably get it second
hand like I said
so that first interaction might even be
a waste I might not even have another
chance with that how do you get it
Second Hand by him writing in notes and
you read it later right I guess so
yeah it's just different why is it like
what how do you quench your thirst in
um so because the way you're viewing it
different than I'm viewing because the
way it sounds like it's like I'm so
thirsty and someone gives you water and
then you're like but my thirst isn't for
knowledge like that like yours okay what
is yours so my interaction with people
is to connect
right connect with people yes whereas
for you you have an agenda not even to
sound bad but for you you're just trying
to you idolize them to some degree and
you respect them and you think they have
they possess something that you admire
so therefore you're trying to learn from
that but I'm also trying to connect too
right but you're trying to learn from
that for me I'm just like is this person
even someone I want to even connect with
if I don't even want to connect with you
as a person that might even ruin me
wanting to learn from you because if
you're such a I might not even
I'm like yeah you're the best but you're
such an that like I don't want
anything to do with you anymore
yeah so if like David Chang is in the
office I mean in the kitchen I'm like
damn I really respect his culinary
um expertise I would like to learn from
him but if he's just talking down to
everyone and being a complete
I'm like oh I'm good I'll learn from
someone else
wow yeah because for me take that waste
of the human being back you son of a
I take it back now give me a
compliment you're beautiful no I need
something deeper than that you said I'm
a waste of a human being yeah that's
huge beautiful is not going to cover
that
um let me brainstorm okay it shouldn't
take this long what the well could
I already merge you and that's the
biggest compliment I don't know how to
shut the up well make it work how
do I supersede that I don't know you
shouldn't have said I'm a waste of a
human being you're definitely not a
waste of human no that's not that
doesn't work prove to me that I'm not
always a human being enough of a human
being for two humans ah you
piece of anyway go ahead
yeah because for me I don't think I
think about how good of a human being
they are
because if someone is interesting I want
to connect with them
and um
if I find out later that they're a
I cut that off because
obviously I value human beings but not
me apparently because I'm a waste I
never cut you off but then I'll be like
I cut them off
um but whatever I learned from that
interaction is valuable because that
interaction is still important
yeah so I guess I'm approaching it
differently right because if I like so I
started this podcast by asking you what
makes you want to meet new people
so I'm I'm I want to connect with
interesting people right so I'm curious
as to why you would want to connect with
this person right so for you it's more
so they're interesting because they have
attributes that you desire right so so
for me if there's someone that's not
necessarily attributes that I desire
but they're interesting
I see like for example one of our recent
guests on jknews Kazumi
she doesn't have any attributes that I
desire I don't want to be in the swinger
World
um I don't really care about only fans
um but her world is outside of mine so
it's extremely interesting so when she
was talking that was one of the most
like locked in I would I I've been
because I'm like oh wow this is really
cool like different perspective it's
like as if I was talking
to someone who lived as a monk in in a
mountain for three years or something
that's the same the same thing like that
yeah yeah but that is
connect with someone
that would just be like Oh I'm gonna
interview but just because I'm
interviewing doesn't mean I want to even
develop a friendship what makes you want
to connect with someone that's what I'm
like what makes you want to connect is
what the
um so then that's where the group
setting comes in or like uh what makes
me want to connect with people is when I
see admirable attributes and I'm like oh
man like I really do look up to this
person or admire this person because of
XYZ XYZ reasons
but off the bat it takes a lot I don't
know maybe the I carry a lot of
trauma or something who knows that I
have you've known this about me but I
just maybe I just have a lot of walls
that I'm just like it could be the
introverted it could be the traumas I
don't know that I'm just like
um it takes quite a bit for me to want
to even connect with people
I see I think I'm I'm similar with you
on that regard where I think
um
I don't care about anyone until they
prove otherwise
because to me I'm like everyone's dumb
including myself
so no one's very special
but if something special that pops out
then I go oh
what is that yeah yeah yeah yeah climb
for a living what the hell you know then
I'm like that's really interesting yeah
for me it takes more than just rock
climbing
um for me it's also just how they view
life but that's how I know that how they
view life
okay
like through what people do and how much
they do it tells me how they view life
well but what if they just grew up in a
family that does it
and that's it they were just born into
it nope nope what they're not going to
be that way
I see you take so you're seeing a
top-tier rock climber that's not just
like a novel take David Goggins yeah I
see you take rock climber yeah you take
uh Circle so you only like High Caliber
lady yeah that could Bend her thing
backwards and pull the arrow with her
toes you take those three you take uh
the number one interior design like
agency in the world
different all different Industries you
give them a multiple choice test about
uh is your life in your own hands of
course it's all the same or is your life
determined by the circumstances around
you yeah no they're gonna answer
identically right absolutely yeah yeah
that's what I mean when I find people
like that I see I know how they view
life yeah and then so when people view
life uh
differently than how I do yeah
I want to learn how they do that is just
having the this physical
uh hobby or skill set if you will that
is what establish Rapport because that
is easier for me
to connect with them through that but
then through that I learn the real
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I can
relate to that
um but when it comes to just off the
blue so again because of the
energy bank or the trauma who
knows I'm just gonna call it the intro
introverted side of me yeah
um
it needs to be pretty black and white
and I need it needs to be pretty
apparent
but for me to go out of my way to
discover that initially I don't really
care to do that like with Kazumi for
example right
um she is a swinger
has sex with tons of people in a
committed relationship
um I don't do any of those things I
don't go to swinger party Stringer
Resorts anything like that but through
sex I am able to understand and learn a
more
um
open-minded and extreme emotional
maturity because if you don't have
extreme emotional and sexual and like
relational and social maturity you
cannot balance a committed significant
other and banging like other people you
know so through that I'm able to learn
about all those things and that's why
for me like when someone stands out I
want to connect because as I connect
with them and understand
um I don't even know maybe it's a
one-way connection maybe they don't feel
connected to me at all but my brain is
is constantly like
expanding in so many different ways yeah
yeah for that to do it in that aspect
that's why I keep saying that like for
you it's it's a lot about like
achievements or perspective and stuff
like that
um I'll do it the same way but for me to
connect off the bat like our neighbor
for example like a neighbor
um I don't really care to strike up that
conversation unless I see like our
neighbor from our old neighborhood that
moved in that had like all the cool toys
in front of his house he had the Bronco
he had a whole bunch of I'm like oh
I'm interested in this person
because I've already seen it like I
don't have to dig around but it's not
the same same thing
um because I want to know about the
achievement stuff but to connect for the
sake of connecting that takes me a long
time
and that's what I mean where I rather do
that in a group setting
so if like Kanye was outside right I'm
probably just gonna fan girl and just
hear about like how his mind works or
whatever but I don't think I'd want to
connect I think I'm gonna interview
same thing with like David Chang I don't
really want to connect I'm just
interviewing and I see those as very
like two different things because when
I'm talking to them on the interview
mode I'm not trying to see how I can
hang out with this person
until I've seen enough or there's enough
um things that I like about them
personally that I'm like oh I
actually want to take this interview to
the next phase which would be some type
of connection
yeah so it's like someone like like
Kanye or David Chang I'll have no
problem I mean I'm a Charming person so
I have no problem making small talk
interviewing doing all that but
um it would be absolutely draining but
if the goal is to learn and interview
what I'm calling the interview mode
then I can do that but to take it past
that takes a lot
that's why my circles are so small
like my whole life all my friend circles
have been
um so small but I've had them for a long
time do you seek interviews
uh it doesn't even seem like you seek
interview situations not as of late but
like you said David Chang was in our
kitchen you wouldn't even want to be
like one-on-one it's just like I mean if
it's something that I'm interested
absolutely I would seek it you know
um if it's something that I'm interested
in for sure I would seek it but I mean
as of lately I mean that doesn't apply
and prior to us moving out here I was
doing a lot of JK and on JK we have a
lot of guests so that was constantly
getting fulfilled you know because I am
like interviewing and like picking their
brand and going like oh that's so
interesting
yeah I see but listening to podcasts is
Super Rad
because I get to fulfill that too
I see yeah
what I feel like you're judging me or
something no I'm just trying to
understand this it's really interesting
yeah it's really hard for me to want to
connect with people okay not hard it's
easy but it takes a lot for me to feel
like okay cool I want to establish a
connection with this person
and I think the older I become what's
your definition of connection because
maybe that's a word I don't understand
um
um wanting to see them more
like more regularly wanting to actually
hang out make plans and like be friends
and even that I do it very minimally
wow yeah I'm telling you I'm
introverted and I don't know if if it
became bigger because of
um uh initially starting with the
lockdown right where we all were forced
to and then us moving out here now where
I'm like this is tight this is so cool
but after three after like a quarter I'm
like okay I need I need something do you
care about tribe
do I care about tribe
in what aspect like if I needed in both
the literal and the modern form of it
uh what's the modern form of it the
modern form of it I think would be like
people that are like-minded similar
values and some and then kind of bond
based off of similar values similar
similar mindset I think that's a modern
form of it okay right like oh yeah like
oh hey this person's an entrepreneur
they're like a a mom too like she's in
my tribe like we see things very
similarly yeah yeah yeah I do care about
that and I think that's what leads me to
this question is like me now curiously
asking like what drives you specifically
to want to make these connections
because for me
um now I'm seeing the value of it more
and more because we are removed and I'm
older and I have taika
um and we're switching you know our our
roles within entrepreneurship and in
family like our roles are shifting as we
speak so because of that it made me
think about this where I'm like hmm like
I see the importance of tribe
um and I do like it
and um now more than ever I am going to
seek that out because I see the
importance of it because the tribe is
actually the opposite of what you've
been doing of duh of course of course
you know but that's why this even this
question even popped based on her
actions I would be like she cares does
not care about of course absolutely you
know but it's something in my brain
that's why that's something that I'm
conscious and aware of
um that's why I even ask you that
question because now I'm going more than
ever I'm realizing
um that it's so important to have
to have your group around you like it's
super duper important so
um I do care about it to answer your
question
yeah I see yeah I really care about it
and I care about it in a bunch of
different ways
I care about it in terms of
um locally
which is why I like you know when I when
we move into a community I try to bond
with all the neighbors yeah and in that
you have to find the diamond and the
rough yeah because not everyone is gonna
be like oh like
we click right away or like you know
we're the same mindset or even with the
same age even you know sometimes you
just ages so off you're just like you
can't even there's no no connection or
even like uh culturally you know someone
recently immigrated here doesn't even
speak the language I don't even know how
to communicate you know
um but for me I'm like it was cool to
meet our other neighbor because I'm like
cool he's down the street
um now we have two people on the same
same page
hits the fan I blow a tire he blows
the tire we can contact each other my
wife needs help his wife needs help boom
yeah yeah this is like the traditional
literal definition of a tribe yeah
because my my definition of a tribe is
flat tire help and then also
like-mindedness yeah doesn't do any good
if like
um me and this other guy are super cool
and we meet and we're Best Buds and then
I need help
and he's nowhere to be found because it
was all clout based or networking based
that's not true tribesmanship yeah yeah
to me so and and as we get older we're
all spread apart right so like Joe's in
My Tribe and I know if it's an emergency
emergency he's gonna fly to me no matter
what yeah but he's in Hawaii
and or we're in LA
and so the tribe is spread apart so I
want to have a local tribe yeah
I want to have my like day one tribe
yeah that's David that's Joe you know
like I want to have my day one tribe
yeah
um but then also also I realize I need
to have tribes for other interests
absolutely because not all of them
overlap yeah and I need all of them
for me to feel fulfilled I need all of
them to have the flat tire mentality
yeah
so it's not good enough that I just
trained jits with these guys I also want
to know like when it's your kid's
birthday you're gonna invite me when
it's my kid's birthday I invite you yeah
yeah yeah in this trip yeah and then in
that try like you know I wanna that's
that's important to me and so that and
that's to answer your question why you
say why are you so down to connect and
put yourself out there because I want to
build the tribe yeah I want to build my
tribe yeah
um and and hearing you talk about all of
this right now I think I just had like
an epiphany yeah so
um which is Super Rad or a breakthrough
if you will so I've been in that mindset
or in this mindset maybe I think more so
than ever
I had it prior maybe like two years ago
because I just had some like real
significant life changes that like I was
doing heavy work on myself right and I
feel like now I'm at a point where I
understand myself enough and the work
doesn't stop but I'm at a point right
now where I can switch the focus on the
initial aspects of my life that I wanted
to change about myself that now I can
have more of like a
um an outwardly
um change that I want because I'm pretty
satisfied where I'm at again the work
doesn't stop and I'm constantly trying
to work on uh like evolving but now I'm
in a comfortable position where I can
look at everything else around me and
create my own space and environment so
um I've been thinking about what all of
that all of that looks like and what
really
turned up the fire if you will was when
taika started having his
um epilepsy
so because of that I really started
looking at like you know the tribe or
whatever like my group of people
um like my counsel too because that's
also what your circles should be it
should be you should have a council of
of like of of your elders if you will
people that have wisdom that you're like
you would go to
um in an event of like an emergency of
some sort or advice
so
um because of that I've just been
thinking of different aspects of who I
am and you know what I want to
contribute to to taika's life and you
know what I want people to contribute to
mine and I want to contribute more
things to my circle and my friends and
just my community
um and now because we're switching our
roles like I'm leaving The Entrepreneur
Space for a bit just so I can really
focus on my son more more than ever
because of his health
that I'm like dang why why is it that I
don't care about seeking these
connections kind of like the whole
conversation we've been having now and
as you were talking
do you remember a few nights ago where I
was like damn you and I were really
self-sufficient people like we don't
really even need each other like
honestly like realistically looking at
it yeah yeah you don't need me and you
know I don't need you yeah so we're here
because we love each other you don't
need me sometimes I don't need you at
all and you know this wait no you need
me I do yeah you miss me like no no for
real be serious okay fine right yeah you
need me a little bit come on you son of
a you don't need me at all right
so so we're super self-reliant which
makes our relationship so rad because we
don't have to lean on each other we're
here because we both want to be here you
know we both see enough value and
respect in each other and in ourselves
to be like I choose you for all the good
reasons the quote an old video a peanut
butter
exactly you know and I'm Jelly so like
when we come together shit's dope yeah
it's magic
um so when I was thinking about that I
was like that's rad not the
relationship part but that we're very
self-sufficient self-reliant and then I
was like but when you come to think of
it that's very sad
what's that that was so self-sufficient
yeah and it's sad because we were forced
to be this way because of how we were
raised or the lack of resources or lack
of
parental uh figures or whatever right
it's sad that backstory is sad the back
story is that so when you think about it
it's kind of it's kind of sad like
obviously it's not sad now because it's
such a wonderful thing to have it's
that's why you and I are both very
confident people because we know we're
highly capable
um but when I was thinking about like
how I became the way I did I'm like oh
man that's a bummer it's because I felt
like I didn't have that support when I
was little that I needed to learn how to
be self-reliant
so I'm like that's a bummer but it's rad
now but the side effect to that is that
I still continue to feel like one I
don't want to burden people with my
so if the flat tire happened I
would probably be Googling how to change
my flat tire I don't think
um
it's your upbringing in that way what do
you mean
sorry I have a hair that was just
itching like scratching on me but
it got it um I think it was you didn't
have your tribe as a kid
that's yeah that's what I think is more
so
that's what I'm saying I don't have that
because I don't think Independence
is has anything to do with tribe you can
have a tribe of fully self-sufficient
dope yeah and because of
that environment everyone becomes even
better superheroes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so okay maybe it wasn't so I don't
think like like um
yeah like it's like okay cool apparent
abandonment whatever that's a lot of
stuff that a lot of people deal with and
it causes self-reliance it's pretty cool
but uh I've also seen Stellar
individuals with a group of Stellar
individuals and then they're become
extra Stellar too yeah maybe that's what
it is I didn't grow up with that
mentality then or with that around I'm
talking about the flat tire I'm not
talking about the physical part of it
because obviously we're self-sufficient
and just AAA what I'm talking about is
the the knowing that someone has your
back the safety net of that yeah like
yeah yeah like if I fell off the toilet
that's cool that like uh like let's say
me and Tim Kennedy are friends now
but if I text him can you come wipe my
ass because I fell off the toilet broke
both my hands should be you have the
confidence I'd be like yeah I'll be
there in five yeah I'm like okay cool
yes he's the he's in the tribe you know
vice versa whatever you know that's
that's what I mean yeah yeah no no I
know that
um but for me that's
so taking it to that I'm going that I
don't even want to be someone's burden
in that way
but you wouldn't if you're in your true
tribe
um and that's where I think of you
saying I never even had it from the
beginning yeah that I'm going like well
why would I do that so I need to rewire
my brain to be like no you do need that
because now what I'm talking about is if
you're a superhero
you don't need someone to change your
tire
what you need is someone that
understands the tax code better than you
so you can add another figure onto your
business yeah that's your new tire yeah
that's what I'm talking about when super
people come together in a tribe it's not
like well this guy's like a doctor and
what can this guy gain from this and how
is it reciprocated it's like no like now
you have a team of doctors this guy
knows how to run a hospital
so it's it's not so much like
um uh
uh emergencies
it's
merge a means
[Laughter]
emerging it's like what happens if like
dude it's not like you have four tires
one blows out it's like yeah what
happens
tires now yeah yeah yeah it's growth
based yeah yeah yeah yeah the council
yeah because like uh like in any
business you should have or not even a
business but if you have a business you
want a council of people that come from
different walks of life businesses uh
economic backgrounds uh so that you
could be like hey this is where I'm at
in this business or this or in my
business what are you guys thinking and
everyone can give you their perspective
and chime in all things because you
respect their opinion and their input
yeah and because and the reason why I
say that is when you're saying you were
forced to do everything yourself because
if you're up yeah it's it's absolutely
not even tied every theme that you're
able to do because of your upbringing
because of your independent is all done
at a
um bare minimum level right right right
like you know how to change your tire
right like a regular person absolutely
not like a F1 pit stop yeah right you
know how to cook not like a like a
regular person right not like David
Chang so what I mean is when uh you have
the right tribe yeah now all of the
Independence that you know is done at a
Michelin star level yeah absolutely and
I agree to I agree with that
for me it's more because I've always
even said this to my dad as far back as
I can remember and it probably started
off in high school I really started
recognizing this
um I would always tell my dad like if
I'm the smartest person in my group I
need a new group exactly yeah so I've
always thought that and I've always seen
the value in that so I'm agreeing with
you 100
um but I think what I've come to realize
now is I've never had that tribe thing
or whatever that you're talking about
that that makes me want to have that
that like I know what it's like
therefore I seek it out more whereas now
I'm going I really need to rewire my
brain yeah because yeah that's what I
was doing when I was growing up where
I'm trying to be the dumbest person in
my group yeah because like I can't know
everything I don't have the time to read
every single book article uh uh
science journal but if I have the right
friends that do that damn just by
osmosis I'm learning all of that yeah
you know it's like like um
for example
we go into Ukraine right I'm like oh
that's what the news tells me off
the off my phone I can text five people
that can give me boots on the ground why
we're really there like that
and that is my tribe so I know all those
guys will wipe my asses my ass too and
I'll wipe their ass but that's like I
think that's what I'm talking about I
think with your tribe since you've never
had that
um I think have been able to like just
tap into a higher Matrix yeah is
dope and then to have that Matrix though
actually care in a real way yeah that's
it where it's not just like okay I know
a lot you know a lot less extreme
favorite a favor but it's more like I
care about your kids and you care about
my kids yeah then it's like now we got
like a real real tribe going on yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no I see I
absolutely see the value in that
um so yeah going back to me going like
yeah I really need to rewire my brain
and more so than ever
um I am super grateful that I am gonna
you know remove myself even more so
because I've been doing this for years
where I'm like taking myself out and out
of like business right like it first
started off with like JK and all the
different things that I was in that I'm
like
um getting away from that so that I can
now go and and build that for myself
which I'm super stoked about but I was
definitely wanting to pick your brain on
it because I'm like well what is it for
you that inspires that because for me
I guess my comfortable space and this is
now another breakthrough that I'm having
that I'm like oh it's because it's
comfortable you know whereas before when
we're younger it's easier to make
friends because it's like you guys
already have like a shared hobby like
college or high school or even the first
workplace but now as you get older it's
a little bit different
yeah yeah mine is
I constantly
um want to be in a place where I don't
know the most
so anytime I feel like I'm getting to
yeah you got to go somewhere else when I
feel like I am the sum of my Collective
Now I need to add another person in but
I it's not that I'm leaving them because
I love the Loyalty that means so much to
me it's just I'm adding more people into
the tribe you know and I can't wait for
my other tribes people to meet each
other yeah you know I can't wait because
that's a true tribe is everyone wipes
everyone asses you know yeah so for me
I'm like I I I'm like okay cool I think
I know about the same as everyone in
this tribe and then the other person
knows about the same as everyone else in
this tribe two now like I'm sure David
probably knows a really good deal about
how to set up a gym and run a gym just
through osmosis with me yeah so now
we're equal on that realm so what's the
next thing we could bring in that we're
all like like that and I constantly
wanna that that makes what makes me seek
out
more people yeah no I need to work on
that maybe I'm going to make that my my
2023 goal is like collecting all of that
um because I do feel like I have that in
my space now but you know through moving
out here and and like
um with taika's health me going like oh
that's not enough
yeah
Mia keeps farting and it's the
worst can you smell it no you
she's right here so she's
I'm her I'm her owner I guess
like she's chosen me yeah right like you
know German Shepherds specifically only
have one owner yeah yeah they choose
that main one that's their that's their
Alpha yeah they care about everyone else
but they they have the person yeah so if
I'm gone your second yeah to that so she
sits next to me and every single
video that we film she farts and it's
thick
and it's like spicy
disgusting it probably has a
little bit turmeric in it it's
disgusting man and it's like I could
imagine how warm it must have felt
coming out of her butt yeah do you know
what I'm talking about yep that's what
it smells like and I'm trying so hard to
be in this moment but I'm like trying to
breathe through my mouth so that I don't
make any like I don't throw you off yeah
or throw off this whole thing and then
it's so hot that I can feel it it's
gross and I feel like I can
almost taste it but don't taste it I'm
not trying to but I it's either I'm
breathing through my mouth or I'm
breathing through my nose you know
through your nose then it's rough it is
rough
um but
yeah no I it's this conversation has
been really rad
um but I really do you know and I love
that I'm aware of it because it's
something that I want to work on so it's
really cool that like I see it now I
have the choice to do nothing about it
and about it the whole time and
still stay in the same spot or be like
okay cool let's get to work yeah like
I'm I'm very proud of my contact list in
my phone yeah and the contact list not
just uh for who's on the list
but the Rapport that I have with the
people that matter to me on that list
yeah because to me it's quality over
quantity yeah
and also the depth of that quality
and So like
um that list is my counsel
so when anything happens I have
questions about anything like the
ability that I know things will be
reciprocated
um
that helps me expand my mind and I feel
like I'm growing in this life
CUNY yeah so but now the only thing is
because we are new residents of an of a
new state we don't have Roots so for me
like the biggest one is building like
the familial tribe and then the
geographical tribe yeah that's why I'm
so eager to meet or even after our old
place I was so eager to become the
neighbors yeah yeah yeah
because you also never like played with
neighbors
but it's honestly like I did it man I
was so isolated literally from
everything it's one of the best things
ever yeah it's amazing like
um
like when the whole street cares about
the whole Street's well-being
and uh everyone all the kids are at one
person's house
and then you see like every parent come
and pick up their kid one by one as if
it's like a daycare Elementary School
it has like this like subconscious like
warm blanket on your heart
you know because you're like oh man like
everyone here cares if I got stuck in
the rain because of working overtime or
whatever
like Jenna is gonna feed taika no
question about it
was a really hot lady that always like
Waters the lawn in this racer shirt and
sprays her own shirt at the same time
okay you know I know Jenna yeah she's
always wearing that white T-shirt she's
always sprayed herself I don't know why
but she always does it yeah yeah she's a
hot lady yeah yeah but like temperature
hot yeah like uh like hot knowing that
you know that's like the kid's ass
wiping where if something happened
um Jen would be like oh it's 10.
what the your parents didn't come
pick you up well yeah just we'll have
another bed you know just just sleep
here and then we'll go find her parents
in the morning like having that what a
weird situation you just painted
but knowing that yeah yeah you know
because someone has your back because
the only other person you know that does
that is probably your brother yeah you
know if we got stuck somewhere like we
had a delayed flight or something like
that your brother like oh um I haven't
heard from Geo or you haven't heard your
mom taika I guess you're gonna have to
stay the night
you know like that type of like
hospitality and warmth when you when the
whole street feels like that it's
freaking dope yeah it sounds really dope
and then like the kids go to each
other's graduations
go to each other's events it's really
cool and then it's almost like like when
they are at that other school they're
like oh who's that oh that's my best
friend from this from from my street
you know and you're like oh wow it feels
like a different like
level of connection because that's so
cool because they grew up together you
know it's not just like oh we're buds
because we went to the same school it's
like they literally like grew up
together yeah yeah yeah no I
know I clue on that I have no clue about
um yeah anything you just explained it
sounds wonderful though that's what I
want like that's why even since our
original neighborhood or even since our
Glendora house you know I was trying to
meet all the neighbors
because that local tribe
um regardless if they have the
characteristics or the council to expand
or whatever that aside is to me is not
that important more so hard it's the
heart yeah you know in the local tribe
it's like can I trust my kids to be at
your house for multiple days can you
trust your kids to be at my house nobody
with my kids and then uh but we need to
no and then uh to to have each other's
backs like that because you just get it
I get what you're saying you know and it
feels good
it feels good um when that happens yeah
you know
I agree yeah I agree it sounds good it's
just again it just has to happen um
I just have a lot of work to do
really
because for you you experience it it's
kind of like me trying to teach you how
to celebrate uh American holidays you're
just like what I didn't I don't know
what any of that like I know the name
yeah I understand the concepts yeah yeah
yeah but what is it really how do you
how does this all unfold
I'm like oh okay so on birthdays this is
what we do and you're like oh I
remember is to this point when one of
the kids on the street got a new dog all
the kids felt like they got a new dog
CUNY yeah like
um my best friend across the street got
a new dog her name was precious and uh
all the kids loved precious so if
precious wandered into their yard
they're calling Hey precious is in my
backyard bring the dog back like it's a
different type of like web you know it's
it was really cool and everyone was
happy everyone felt like they got a new
dog
okay well I'll give that to taikum but I
never had I'll give it to my dude so
ah gotta meet people huh
it ain't even all that no it is bad it's
pretty bad I gotta change that
um I'm not gonna abandon it's bad when
the way is to pull into the garage is
the neighbor literally comes out and
it's like this and you're like you put
back the car into the garage I'm not
that bad no I would say hi I make eye
contact like I'm not awkward to say hi
as it's going like this no I don't no I
don't that you're you're painting an
exaggerated picture I'm not an awkward
social you're not awkward at all I'm
very personable yeah I know how to
connect instantly
um but for sure I'm dying on the inside
absolutely I'm just like oh God make it
but on the outside it seems like I want
to talk more and more more
I get that from my mom my mom's the
exact same way she like seeks out
conversations because she's so charming
and she's so sweet and then at the end
of it she's like dying and I'm like why
did you even make eye contact
yeah
anyway
I got a lot of work to do I get it
um but on that note
that's it I'm done anything else you
want to add
all right well on that note we do have
um a sponsor on this podcast yes the
sponsors podcast is brought to you or
this podcast is brought to you by Barlow
Brigade
um if you're looking for dope Fitness
stuff always check out Marvel
brigade.com we spend a lot of time
making some of the swaggiest gear ever
um we just recently dropped some mesh
shorts we got the City of Angels hoodie
over that's probably sold out by the
time this podcast comes out but every
single month we're having a sick drop
whether it's tanks hoodies tees shorts
if you guys have owned any pair of our
amphibious shorts you know how high
quality it is and that's one of the
beauties of having a mom-and-pop
ownership where it's not about Mass
Appeal we're really trying to produce
things that we're really proud of and
you'll see me literally wear every
single day except for today for some
reason you're wearing it underneath oh
yeah true your shirt yeah true watch I
bet you anything it's a barbell shirt
yep there it is go to bottlebrigade.com
get your supplements your apparel your
digital training program see you guys
next time bye